i want to turn out to an important story
out of california a
pastor has been using an unconventional
method to deal with racism for the last
two years he's treating it
like an addiction now his effort is
going global the pastor was inspired by
the teachings of
alcoholics anonymous and he's using the
very same methods
our story is part of our series unifying
america where we recognize people who
are trying
to write injustices and bring
communities together
carter evans now has more hi i'm tiffany
i'm a racist
it's surprising to hear hi i'm pam i'm a
racist
and even harder to admit nobody really
likes owning or being referred to as a
racist
doug who asked us to use only his first
name is a member of racist
anonymous a 12-step program like a.a
i'm doug i'm a racist he joined last
summer after the police raid that killed
brianna taylor in his hometown of
louisville kentucky
doug says he realized he was part of the
problem
what are some of the racist behaviors
that you see in yourself
i make judgments about people based on
the color of their skin
i do it all the time is it just
african-americans
anyone other than me really it's sort of
built into our society
to look down on certain people who are
different
and we often seem to mistreat people
based on those differences pastor ron
buford started racist anonymous
six years ago cbs news visited his
sunnyvale california church
in october of 2016. there are
a number of black people and some of
them have these weird names
and somehow i just can't remember those
weird names
and i'm very i feel very bad about it
you might want to use unique or
different because i don't think the
mother would like you to say
a child has a weird name what racist
anonymous is about
is about getting more aware of the fact
that it's not just
some people who do that we all do that
to some degree
would you say you're racist yup
absolutely i say it every week in the
meeting
so let's begin moving the conversation
online during the pandemic
opened up the meetings to people beyond
this northern california town
and inspired dozens of similar groups
around the world
here at home amid one of the most
racially turbulent times since the 60s
racist anonymous is more relevant than
ever
i have come to admit that i am powerless
over my
addiction to racism nancy joined six
months ago to better understand
prejudice she says she learned from her
parents
do you think you still have some of
those racist tendencies i do
because to this day if i see
someone with like a a head scarf
like hijab or yes my heart just kind of
clenches
how do you feel when you react that way
now now terrible
but also better it's helped me to
identify
all of these feelings that i had just
bottled up
[Music]
they're challenging racial turmoil by
first confronting
themselves so i've made a calculation in
my head that this is worth it
outing myself here so that others can
see it and maybe be inspired to do
something about themselves
and potentially transform society
it's worth owning what i just don't what
do you get out of
declaring in front of other people
that you're a racist well it
desensitizes it it brings the fear level
down
of admitting that you're wrong i hope
it becomes common for people to think of
themselves
as being racist and
wanting to get it out of them it takes a
discipline
it takes work it takes thinking and
just starting the conversation virginia
welcome for cbs this morning carter
evans
sunnyvale california wow carter evans
wow wow
it was just hard to hear somebody say my
name is tiffany and i'm a racist
i really appreciate the candor that they
all said that they all admitted
how they became including the pastor
himself including pastor ron
yeah this is a great idea can't make an
acknowledgement like that we've all
grown up in this country we see the
outcomes we see what happens here
uh if you can't make that
acknowledgement then you can't make
change right well but it's
your piece a few months back pointed out
you know a lot of people
saw the problems with race but didn't
want to touch that word
the word shuts down conversation in many
cases so if you can desensitize people
to it as she said
very effective that is progress and to
do it full face too
what's the question anthony you say
about racism that you don't say are you
racist
oh yeah you had an alternative you had a
really good it was my alternative
no no you had a really good phrase you
said don't ask people are they racist
you should ask when we were talking
about this chad wolfe
for example you were interviewing the
trump administration yeah no it was
there's a different approach
because there's so many phrases there's
so many white people that word is
very loaded yeah and they're and and
they're scared of it because they think
it means
oh you're in the ku klux klan yeah
you're going to be yeah from society
right but you i mean
that word is so much more subtle and
there's there's so many so many more
subtle ways you can do racist
which is which is what many of those
people are speaking to there's a really
good phrase you have we have to
figure it was good